unsere Hazel Donuts gibt es ab sofort
exklusiv überall bei Kaufland
hallo zusammen heute gibt es einen sehr
besonderes Video es wird lecker
also wir haben ein bisschen was gemacht
den Vergangenheit was sie nicht so
mitbekommen habt
und zeigen euch was wir gemacht haben ab
heute gibt es nämlich exklusiv in einem
Kaufland Filialen deutschlandweit unsere
eigenen Bruder
und nicht nur irgendwelche Donuts denn
nicht machen wir uns kennt kann sich ja
denken okay
gefällt mit unserer Haselnusscreme danke
starten können jetzt hier mit diese
Cream ist drin also es ist wirklich
unsere original Hazel creep hätte die
probiert hat kann sich ja denken wie
diese Donuts schmecken ihr könnt sie
euch ab heute in den Kaufland Filialen
schnappen aber wir haben ja auch super
coolen Clip mit Kaufland gedreht
zusammen mit Julia mit so einem riesigen
ich glaube gefühlt 30 köpfigen Kamera
und Police Team und wir ganz schön viele
du hast gegessen ich habe an dem Tag
insgesamt sieben von den hazeldorf
gegessen diesen wirklich unfassbar
lecker aber kommen wir mal zu dem
Drehtag so ein kleiner Clip der aber
eigentlich super aufwendig war im
Background was da alles abging Leute
also erstmal wurden wir super
professionell zurecht gemacht mein
Outfit war so an Hazel inspiriert Julias
Outfit war an Ihrem Haus gebracht
inspiriert und Hamza war der der Frau
Charlie und die Schokolade
es war wirklich surreal ne einfach so
ein zuckerwattenbaum eine Brücke dann
riesen Lollipops und es war schon das
war eigentlich so kindisch dass das
schon so richtig cool und erwachsen war
wirklich so einfach gehalten dass das so
so cool wurde besetzt diese
Zuckerstangen
gebastelt mir egal ja echt gut gestanden
also letztes
und diesmal hatte ich eine zu enge Hose
und hat einfach nicht gesehen unter mein
Hemd dass ich mein Hemd also das
eigentlich zu eng weil ich habe es gar
nicht zugemacht
ja voll witzig Regisseur der hat
Leute der war einfach drin in diesem
Film das war so krass
der war richtig wirklich
seinen Film im Kopf gehabt
[Musik]
ja richtig schauspielerisches Talent und
ich bzw auch wir so dagegen okay bin so
richtig Amateure und dann hat er so
richtig abgeholt
euch am Ende des Videos mal anschauen
und auf jeden Fall Feedback da lassen so
am Ende seht ihr das ist eine riesen
Donut Maschine gab wo wir dann einfach
Knöpfe drücken konnten und dann konnte
ich halt überlegen okay womit soll
weggeführt sein womit soll er getoppt
sein und dann drückt man halt wirklich
auf den Knopf und dann kommt
produziert genau ganz einfach
produziert für ganz Deutschland ganz
Deutschland Kaufland natürlich anders
wir waren in der Versuchsküche komm in
meine Donut Produktion
und dann konnte ich wirklich gucken okay
wie soll der Donut Teig sein wie soll
die Füllung sein bei der Füllung muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen easy peasy da
kommt meine originale
genau so da brauchen wir eigentlich
nicht wir sind einfach mit dem einmal in
die donutfabrik lass uns mal
experimentieren und dann hat man noch
einen coating dann hat man noch ein
Haselnuss Krokant ihr wisst ich liebe
Haselnusskuchen wie dick ist es on top
wie viel Füllung kommt wie viel Prozent
von den Haselnuss Krokant kommt on top
also man könnte wirklich alles richtig
fein kalibrieren und alles mit bestimmt
und das finde ich so cool und deswegen
auch an der Stelle einfach mal Props an
Kaufland dass wir uns einfach machen
dass das für einfach dieses Projekt mit
euch realisieren können
so wie intensiv oder schmecken so dass
weniger noch mehr ein bisschen dunkler
bisschen heller also war schon vieles
ähm dem Tag eigentlich gegessen
im Endeffekt ist ja ein ganz normaler
Haselnuss kokant mit dem großen
Unterschied dass
also ich gebe wirklich ich sage das
nicht nur weil es irgendwie jetzt
irgendwie unser Selbst Kreta Donuts es
ist eine zwölf von zehn und alles da
drunter hätte ich gar nicht abgesehen
und hätte gesagt lass uns noch mal ein
bisschen versuchen und experimentieren
aber das ist doch ein einfacher Donut
der auch preislich wirklich
attraktiv ist also für neues Cent das
ist keine jetzt 5 € Donut oder so wollen
noch mal irgendwie drauf geklatscht
worden ist und groß und so fett was
einfach wirklich Preis
Leistungsverhältnis top eigentlich
besser gerade mit dieser Creme stimmt
die Kaufland Filialen Leute es gibt
dabei gut ankommt
wir können uns auch gerne wenn ihr das
ganze probiert mach doch den Test das
heißt markiert Kaufland markiert uns auf
Instagram oder auf tik tok und dann
macht den test test ich bin so gespannt
ihr findet die Donuts übrigens in den
kaufland-bäckereien es gibt immer diese
Bäckerei man kommt rein man kann sich da
irgendwie Muffins holen Brötchen oder
sowas und da gibt es die auch dann
unsere Donuts mit der hasencreme und es
gibt natürlich noch mal zwei Pack
deswegen kann man das auch für den
Partner die Freundin der Partner eine
Partnerin der Ehefrau
direkt an mitnehmen Opa alle Kenntnis
geben mit zwei Pack ja ich würde mal
sagen
abzukaufland guckt euch das Video noch
mal an ne das habe also den Clip den
Werbeclips und wir haben seit Gärtner
findet
mich irgendwie einfach was ihr wollt mit
mir ist egal und die habe ich einfach
gerne genommen
also ganz viel Spaß beim test test Leute
wir hoffen dass bei euch so ein bisschen
überrascht haben mit diesem riesen
Projekt und ja ich bin einfach oder
reinzukommen
auch gerne Videos macht Vergleiche gerne
noch mit Julias und falls es richtig gut
ankommen bei euch dann können wir
vielleicht noch ein zweites Projekt
reden genau
also bis dann tschüss
[Musik]